Já ta perdendo
Mas quem que é
F****-se
puto
nao gritas tao alto
[Risos altos]
Como irritar um jogador de LOL, dois!!
[Comemoração]
[Gritos altos]
Pode fazer tudo que quiser,
mas não desligue o PC.
Oque?
Oque que é um PC?
Explique-me oque é um PC.
Um PC é isto!?
Isto é um PC!
Isso é um PC!?
é isto um PC?
Sai daí c***lho
[Gritos altos]
aiaiai
fod&#@e
puto
Desligou a merda do PC p**o
Eu estava a ganhar p**o
É windows 10 ou windows 7?
Eu vi ali um 10!
Está comendo pêssego por que?
Ainda não acabou de comer o pêssego
Por que não come mais pêssego?
PARA COM ESSA MERDA
espalhas-te a senha
*digitando*
Agora todos sabem sua senha
Miguel Monteiro
Sua conta do LOL vai ser hackeada
Sera que dá pra jogar LOL com controle?
será?
tenta usar o controle e bom. battlefield 4, isso não dá
pra jogar lol!!!
será que este Mouse da para jogar LOL
isto não é da razer
devia ser raser
não quer usar um dá raser?
Sério!?
Qual a piada desta merda?
mais é sério qual é?
é o video
legal
EU QUERO, LÁ QUERO SABER DE VIDEO
put*
eu quero ganhar visualizações
eu preciso de visualizações Miguel!
VISUALIZAÇÕES! (gritos muito alto)
Já andas-te de cavalo? Tem que ter um cavalo, então manda a corda!
fodaaaa
muito booom mds
VAI CAVALO!
WOOOOOOOOOOOOO!!!!!!
CAVALO!!!
AAAAAAH!
Eu estou escondido atrás da cadeira games
PORQUE EU SOU YOUTUBER!!!
EU TENHO UMA CADEIRA, UMA CADEIRA GAMER!!!
Ahhhh!!!
Estou protegido, a minha defesa me protege-me
Ouvis-te Miguel Monteiro, ouvis-te, ouvis-te?!?!
Num planeta existia Coca-cola voadora
F***-se put*
(risos)rsrsrsrsrsrsrsrsrsrs
Pessoal, desodorante para chulé também voa
Aii!
Desculpa ai, put*, Desculpa ai, desculpa, desculpa!!!!
TU SABE FICAR QUIETO CARALH*
NÃO SABE FICAR QUIETO COM ESSA MERD* PUT*
NÃO SABE FICAR QUIETO PUT*
Olha o que você fez aqui!!!
agora vou sentar nessa cadeira!!!
foda-s*!!!
Me deixa jogar a por** do LOL, mano!
Miguel Monteiro você molhas-te uma cadeira, a cadeira vai se vingar, o ataque não
foi efetivo!
Paraa, paraa, put*! (Risada)
Para aiiii, caralh*! Fod@-s*! (palavrões)
Qual é teu Rank? É o Rank do pêssego!?!
Tu não queres saber não entende nada disto. >:(
Eu entendo! Esta Vodafone vou revelar o teu código PIN, agora!
Qual é tua rede de celular? Me diz, qual lé? 91, 92, 93? Qual lé?
qual lé?
Você é moche?
TMN?
Aia ia ai
Não seja agressivo Miguel Monteiro!
(Gritos de susto)
Ei put*, fica quieto com essa merd@!
eu sou um Charizard
tu és doente
Olha já vou perde olha ai
Você não sabe o ataque do Charizard você devia saber quem é, Miguel Monteiro!
Não jogues LOL, joga Pokémon Go, é melhor Pokémon Go! é melhor pokémon go!!!
tu morres-te Miguel Monteiro seu feeder
! Como é que Vc Ta vivo ainda? 1/4 seu feeder! Feeders não merecem viver.
Feeders mereçem morrer!!! (gritos e risadas altas)
(Risos finos)
Alguma coisa se passou? Oque se passa Miguel Monteiro
Agora você vai me obedecer, Miguel Monteiro
Agora vai jogar o lol
Para! Para! Eu não estou brincando put*! Para quieto!
(gritos altos de dor)
(risos)
(gritos altos de  dor em câmera lenta)
Put*, isso dói pra c@ralh*!
Estás ferido Miguel Monteiro?!?!
É melhor jogar LOL, não fiques AFK! Vai ser reportado! (AFK é quando a pessoa fica off-line no meio da partida online)
Eu vou te reportar! A minha pistola vai te reportar!!!
Vou disparar na tua lata!!!
Disparei na lata!
Fica quieto com essa merd@, put*!
Já recuperaste o jogo Miguel? Não? Estás com 1/5!!!!!
Ainda esta pior agora!
Esta irritado Miguel? >:D
Put* fica quieto com está merd@!
Olha ai, olha ai!
Esta morrendo?! Esta morrendo?!
Está devagar! Muito devagar, devagar! Muito devagar!
Vai morrer Miguel Monteiro! Vai morrer!!!
AAAAAAAH!!!!!!!!
AAAH!!!!
AAAAAH!!! (Risos)
LOL é tóxico, LOL estraga as pessoas Miguel!!
Sorri, sorri pra mim!!!!
Tu não é o Joker? (coringa em ingles)
Já não está usando o teu fone porque Miguel Monteiro, devia usar os teus fones sempre em todo o jogo!
Isso mesmo Miguel! Agora tu mereces uma festa!!!
Uma festinha sim!!!
PARAAA!!!!!>:C
Alguém está morto, alguém vai comprar itens na loja estando morto! Como é que é possível? Tu es mesmo um demônio!
Isto não pode ficar assim!!!
Tabuleiro OUIJA, será que o Miguel é um demônio?
Meu Deus, estou sentindo ele respondendo, estou sentindo a presença demoníaca!!!!!!
Ohhh, ele disse que sim!!!!
Não merece viver, sai demônio! Saiii! SAI, SAI DEMÔNIO!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, saí demônio!!!!!!
FICA QUIETO COM ESSA MERD@, PUT*!
Saii!
Eu sei que vc é um demônio Miguel! Hoo! Hoo! Hoo!
Charizard, te escolho!!!
Aaah!!!!!
Aaaaaaah!!!!!
F*d@-se Put*, eu perdi mano
Larga a maldição Miguel Monteiro
eu sei que vc é um demônio, larga o
meu amigo, larga meu amigo demônio
larga essa cadeira, não existe Miguel
Monteiro, vai Miguel Monteiro!
Para com essa merd@!!!
Miguel Monteiro, diz só
deixem o like e o favorito :)
LIke favorito (2x)
YAAAAAAY!!! :D
Para, para, para... :(
Diz adeus!
Aaaaah!
Diz Adeus. >:(
Adeus.
tchau
AAAAAH!!!
(risada)
HIhihiihi